[Music]
that's where thinking for yourself comes
in yeah you won't hold fast to something
unless you understand it yourself
there's an old saying
give a person a fish and they eat for a
day
teach a person to fish and eat for a
lifetime
and there's a similar thing for thinking
if you give somebody advice about a
problem they might solve that one
problem
if you teach them how to think about
problems they can solve problems for the
rest of their life
and so that's the way to go
and also if you give them advice and
they don't know understand what the
advice is or how to think about it
there's a good chance they won't take
their advice
i'll give you an example
back in 1991
i was invited to
review the portfolio of
mckenzie and company back in
new york
and so they had a profit sharing and a
pension plan
and i came and i uh looked
at all the things they had and the
things they had were really quite good
but there was one very strange
investment they had it printed out
one or two percent a month every month
they've been doing it for years
they had a record going back into the
late late 60s supposedly
and i said how do they do this and
they said well
we don't know exactly they tell us that
they won't explain what their method is
but we can show you our accounts so i
looked at their accounts
and
i saw that
this account bought stock
and it uh put
option positions on call callers they
had a put option a little below stock
price and they bought a call option a
little bit above
and that
the two things paid for themselves were
self-financing
so they didn't have apparently a whole
lot of risk
but i could show that in a down market
they would lose in a down month in an up
month they would win but they won every
month
and the reason they went every month
was because
a mysterious trade was put on
involving s p index options and it was
always in the right direction so if they
were going to lose it would be a winner
and if they're gonna win you'll be a
loser
so i said this is this is not possible i
said i want to go over and look at this
place
so they called
the person in charge who happened to be
at that time peter madoff the brother of
bernie madoff bernie was off in europe
raising money this was 1991 mind you
and
so when peter madoff heard i was coming
he said no i won't i won't let him in
the front door
so i held my nose and i said i want to
take a better look at all this so i
looked at all their trades and i saw
that
half the trades never happened when i
researched them
that is there was
no trades occurred on any exchange at
the prices they were making them at for
these options
another
quarter of the trades
had
so much volume
that
the volume couldn't have happened
because there wasn't that much volume on
the exchanges where they
traded the last quarter of the trades
which consisted of 40 or 160 to start
with the last quarter of the trades
didn't happen anywhere there was no
explanation so i said okay let's
look at some of the trays that actually
could have happened
so i went to a vice president of bear
stearns
rest in peace
and
said you know we do a lot of business
together
i'd like to ask you a special favor
which you might or might not be able to
grant
i'm going to give you 10 options trades
i'd like to know
who was on the other side of these
trades
in particular was
made often company on the other side of
any of them
so they researched the trades and they
came back and said no can't find any
trace of any made often company
so i said to mackenzie this is a fraud
and they said but we're making 20 a year
i said well you're making 16 of your
current and your other investments
would you rather
if i'm right
this 20 is not real and the roof's gonna
fall in someday and
you might lose your jobs
on the other hand
if i am right
and you move
you have saved this problem
if i'm wrong and you move you're only
going from 20 to 16
so you know it makes a lot of sense
to just
exit
so they exited in two months
we inquired of everybody we knew i threw
my network they threw their network to
find out who had investments with madoff
and how much they had
now we could only cover a small part of
the territory because our network was
not comprehensive
and it turned out that
about
half a billion we were able to identify
now
that means that there was a lot more
than half a billion out there how much
more we couldn't say
but things were looking very bad
on the other hand how could you
challenge madoff he was a pillar of the
national association of securities
i think he'd been a
past president he'd been uh on
committees there he was the biggest
third market that has brought the
exchange maker in the country
so
a respected person
and well known to everybody and he had
thousands of investors as it turned out
and because he had so many investors
everybody knew it had to be right
because surely those people have checked
it all out
now
finale of the story is that when i was
doing this the person who invited me who
was a hedge fund manager himself
who invited me to
do this for mckenzie he had been an
advisor to them
this person
believed in madoff continued to go out
and raise money for him
and in 2008 when the news came out that
madoff was a fraud
my son called me up and said you know
dad the stuff you've been telling me
about for 17 years has finally happened
it blew up
so anyhow this fellow who had been
running a fund of funds and included
madoff in that fund of funds there uh
it's a special type of hedge fund that
invests in other hedge funds he had been
doing this and had a very big fund to
funds
he was raising money
for madoff the same week that the bad
news came out and he had his own
personal money
and his family's money
and trust fund money with madoff
but i had explained everything to him in
great detail i knew him quite well at
the time back in 1991
that
mckenzie and company had
had this analysis explaining to them and
decided to pull out
so the whole point of this is here's a
person who had all the information
it was explained very clearly and he
just
didn't believe it
and he himself was in the investment
business and was very successful
but
he was a reporter
in times past and
his family made a lot of money
in the 30s he was
came from a rich family in chicago
and the way he figured things out was he
would pull people and he would ask
people what they thought about something
it would be like i asked you
what's the
best diet pill i can take you'd probably
say there aren't any good ones and i'd
probably agree with you but uh right
he'd ask a hundred people and then
they would in fact be a poll and he'd go
by the poll
so just imagine that you
asked
ten thousand people
whether
they thought
you could travel faster than light
and
all but one said
yep you can do it
i saw it on tv
and only one guy said no you can't do it
albert einstein
so
a guy like him would overwhelmingly
reject einstein and believe the the 10
000 average people who
just said yeah you could do it
because the poll was
9999 to one
on one side
so
he doesn't think for himself he lets he
lets the crowd think for him
and
that i think is a fundamental mistake
that many people make they let the crowd
do their thinking they don't figure it
out for themselves
you